[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait la répartition des richesses
alors que les grandes entreprises du cac
40 ont annoncé de substantiels bénéfices
pour l'année à 2021 les profits cumulés
du cac 40 devrait atteindre 130,7
milliards d'euros soit plus qu'en 2019
avant la crise sanitaire total vient
d'annoncer un bénéfice record de 14
milliards d'euros suivi vous le voyez de
lvmh 12 milliards d'euros bnp paribas
9,5 milliards d'euros de tels profits ne
concerne pas seulement la france où le
cac 40 aux etats unis le bénéfice des
entreprises notamment dans la tec ont
également explosé par ailleurs
l'inflation en france va s'accélérer
elle se maintiendra entre 3 et 3 5% sur
un an à l'horizon de la fin juin selon
l'insee deux coups le pouvoir d'achat
devient l'une des préoccupations
majeures des français en pleine campagne
présidentielle alors comment expliquer
d'abord de tels profits après deux ans
de pandémie la rémunération des
actionnaires se fait-elle au détriment
des salariés comment mieux répartir la
richesse on débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés daniel la
baronne bonsoir son est député la
république en marche d'indre-et-loire
vice président de la commission des
finances bienvenue dans le débat en face
de vous benjamin coriat bonsoir
économiste membre des économistes
atterrés votre dernier livre benjamin
coriat le bien commun le climat et le
marché réponse à jean tirole c'est aux
liens qui libèrent nous avons également
avec nous par skype de miami denis
jacquet bonsoir denis jacquet
entrepreneur fondateur du mouvement des
one hauteur de covin le début de la peur
la faim d'une démocratie aux éditions
eyrolles bienvenue également
bonjour avec nos également erwan tison
économiste directeur de l'institut à
sapiens bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
également
je voudrais démarré avec vous benjamin
coriat comment expliquer de tels profits
après deux ans de pandémie est ce que
c'est vraiment le rebond d'une activité
en fait qui est même un peu surpris tout
le monde oui
le niveau de reprise surprend tout le
monde n'y a pas l'ombre d'un doute alors
comment l'expliquer il ya plusieurs
plusieurs éléments bon la politique
monétaire extrêmement laxiste un qui a
été menée par la banque centrale
européenne par un parent par la fed
depuis de nombreuses années a permis
d'alimenter un la spéculation en bourse
il ya aucun doute là dessus et donc ça
ça a été un élément
qui est qui est pas négligeable
ensuite pour le cas plus particulier de
la france le quoi qu'il en coûte 1 a
incontestablement joué un rôle très
important au delà du simple rôle
amortisseur qui était absolument
indispensable on voit bien que une
grande partie est passé dans les profits
donc moi je vais être tout à fait clair
le quoi qu'il en coûte il fallait le
faire donc je n'ai pas de souci
là-dessus mais après coup quand on voit
les effets très inégaux et comment ça
vient alimenter les profits et les
surprofits des grands groupes dayya les
rectifications à faire mais c'est
l'objet du débat c'est l'objet du débat
daniela baroness que c'est justement
grâce à ces aides publiques que le cac40
ait pu connaître de six grands profits
en tout cas en tous les cas moi
j'observe déjà que les entreprises du
cac 40
elle réalise 60% de leurs profits dans
le reste du monde elle emploie un tiers
seulement des salariés de leurs salariés
en france et
réalise un tiers de leur chiffre
d'affaires uniquement en france donc il
faut relativiser les choses ça ne peut
pas être le quoi qu'il en coûte qui
profitait à
mai mais par emmanuel macron également
par bruno le maire et par là par les
députés de la majorité a participé un
peu long quand même que 98 % de nos
entreprises sont des tpe et des pme et
que si on regarde mais non vous êtes qu
absolument absolument gras ce n'est pas
qu'à total d'après ce que j'ai lu qui en
fait aurait refusé les aides publiques
oui mais parce que total a bénéficié de
l'augmentation très importante du prix
de l'énergie sans rien faire et
donner jacquet aux etats-unis aussi il
ya fort des profits records à une
reprise très forte des grandes
entreprises américaines qui ont fait les
bénéfices ont progressé là-bas de 4,5
pour cent d'ailleurs d'après ce que j'ai
vu donc bénéfices record là bas aussi
oui c'est clair alors le en fait ce que
je m'entendais de monsieur le député est
vrai et faux
alors je partirais du cac 40 qui ont au
contraire presque prêt de perdre leurs
employés de leurs profits et des
affaires qui se sent pas en france on
tient en moyenne c'est vrai
particulièrement c'est faux mais de
l'autre côté ces choses on a
repris c'est relativement simple à
rentrer de l'argent d'un codeur or de
l'autre pendant je vide
particulièrement dans les pays bon avis
ont une réaction à ces hystériques à dax
la france l'italie où
on a eu effectivement on a qui met ses
démesures fantastique puis il fallait
comme vous disais je la main tout de
suite il fallait faire le poids qui
quand il fallait le faire trop quatre
mois l'a maintenue au-delà
en dehors de toute heure principe de
réalité on nous réduit effectivement
très vite arrêter tout ça on reprendre
une vie à peu près normale avoir une
gestion de la crise sanitaire qui soit
plus proche de ce qu'on a pu connaître
en suède ici en floride au texas et dans
pratiquement la majorité d'ailleurs des
des pays du monde et si finalement on
n'aurait pas eu besoin d'aller voir le
garagiste dire face la voiture il
suffisait qu'il la casse pas en premier
lieu donc il est ici ça s'est bien passé
aussi parce que trump a injecté lui
aussi est batman ensuite des plans un
monstrueux qui ont permis effectivement
d'injecter beaucoup d'argent dans
l'économie a racheté beaucoup de dettes
rachetées beaucoup d'obligations des
bons du trésor etc a aidé beaucoup les
particuliers aussi un puisque pour la
première fois je pense dans l'histoire
des états unis des subventions ont été
versées aux particuliers semaine par
semaine jusqu'à 2000 $ ce qui est du
jamais vu aux états unis donc l' épargne
a été extrêmement riche et d'ailleurs
vous le retrouve sous forme de
l'inflation aujourd'hui et puis les
charges ont été diminués évidemment
toutes les entreprises et aujourd'hui
avec des charges au quotidien les ont
pas eu pendant pâtit donc on a des
bénéfices font peur mais c'est une
situation tout à fait provisoire et 30
mois est absolument pas d'arêtes annie
de la croissance ni de l'activité de ces
entreprises on vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que dit denis jacquet ça sera
temporaire cette explosion des profits
et c'est lié aussi à donc ces politiques
dead
oui et non il ya un effet rebond c'est
certain on le voit l'économie française
affiche une résilience qui est qui est
assez intéressante je pense que
d'ailleurs cette résidence là ce rebond
a été permis en grand partie grande
partie grâce au programme justement du
quoi qu'il en coûte notamment grâce au
chômage partiel on le voit dans la
plupart des pays qui ont un rebond
économique beaucoup plus forts ont des
pays qui d'une part sont ceux qui ont
plus plonger mais aussi ceux qui ont
permis justement de sauvegarder les
compétences et de garder l'emploi pour
permettre d'avoir les personnes à
disposition à un moment la reprise après
il ya aussi quelque chose de conjoncture
et vous savez le cac 40 n'est pas n'est
pas en madiran croissance que depuis
quelques mois ça fait quand les cannes
sur une dynamique depuis quelques années
parce que tout simplement on a les
champions français qui sont excellents
sur leur domaine d'activité je pense au
domaine du luxe notamment à les
entreprises rappelle l'école qui sont
parmi les meilleurs au monde dans leur
secteur et donc du coup qui ont une
ingénierie une technicité qui font qu'en
fait elle réalise des profits pour tout
simplement parce que leur activité
fonctionne de manière phénoménale donc
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il faut peut-être
de temps en temps se dire que il ya des
répliques qui ne sont pas uniquement
conjoncturel mais bien se félicite et
qu'on ait des réussites françaises parce
que ça profite aussi non seulement aux
salariés d'entreprise aller aussi à tout
le reste de l'économie française
benjamin koré alors du coup évidemment
la question du pouvoir d'achat se pose
en raison de la hausse des prix de
l'inflation ça va dépendre évidemment de
la durée de cette inflation est ce que
les entreprises finalement font le choix
des actionnaires au détriment des saints
arie abel depuis plusieurs années je
pense que c'est à peu près incontestable
je veux dire il a du point de vue de la
distribution des dividendes on est entre
60 et 80 % des profits qui sont rendus
aux actionnaires c'est des chiffres
absolument record donc là il ya un vrai
problème il ya une chose que je voudrais
rajouter par rapport à la halle à à la
croissance qu'on vienne traverser
paradoxalement 1
paradoxalement la croissance est due à
la faiblesse française ça veut dire que
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas d'industrie
c'est parce qu'on a plus d'industrie et
donc on va revenir très directement sur
la question des pouvoirs d'achat et que
notre croissance se fait essentiellement
sur les services qu'on a pu avoir un tel
rebond l'allemagne qui est un pays
industrialisé lui peu pays n'a pas pu
parce que l'arrêt de la croissance
mondiale pendant la période du qu il a
fait que et bah ils sont tombés même
même moment du rebond à une croissance
relativement faible bon donc on a on a
un vrai problème alors par rapport à ce
qui a été dit moi je veux bien qu'on ait
des grands champions nationaux mais que
ces grands champions nationaux soit
comme ça a été dit
internationalisé aux deux tiers que les
chaînes de valeur soit construite de
telle manière que pour l'essentiel ça ne
se fait pas en france que l'emploi ne se
fait pas en france c'est pour ça que je
disais que notre rebond il est lié à
l'absence d'industries un donc je veux
dire il n'y a pas que des avantages à
avoir des entreprises comme celles qu'on
a internationalisé dont l'essentiel de
l'activité se fait à l'extérieur et dont
la lucrativité est construite sur des
chaînes de valeurs dans lesquelles la
france ne joue qu'une un petit rôle et
se partage de la valeur justement au
sein de l'entreprise en faveur des
actionnaires vous dites plutôt que mais
ça c'est tout à fait incontestable je
veux dire la lasse pas dû aux
actionnaires au cou s'est passé pas
purement français d'ailleurs
c'est un phénomène mondial et l'équipe
d'antoine
50% à peu près en tout cas de cette
valeur va dans les poches avait un
chalet pour un bien davantage suivant
les échos ont pas si on parle de la
situation française
il faut en revenir aux par exemple aux
chiffres de la comptabilité nationale
bon vous savez qu'on crée de la richesse
de la valeur ajouté et on s'intéresse à
la répartition de cette valeur ajoutée
entre la rémunération des salariés la
rémunération du travail du facteur
salaires et la rémunération du leader
capitale et puis l'ex-sénateur
l'important c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'excédent brut d'exploitation bon eh
bien quand on regarde cet indicateur qui
est un indicateur de profits au sens
large eh bien quelle est la part des
profits dans la création de richesse est
bien c'est de parler relativement stable
depuis une vingtaine d'années mais
c'était parce que la rupture a eu lieu à
20h que ça s'arrête parce que vous le
savez très bien parce que la rupture a
eu lieu avant la rupture a eu lieu dans
les années 80 à partir duquel la
répartition globale de la valeur ajoutée
a connu un mouvement de 10% en faveur
des profits alors depuis c'est à peu
près stable c'est très motivant c'est
donc donc 6 avec une invitation au fait
qu'ils renault mais attendez dont on
parlait de là on parlait de deux
questions qui ces deux questions
différentes un yaya lac nord mais à la
question de la comptabilité nationale à
laquelle vous faites référence essais
des indicateurs qu'il faut considérer
bien entendu je suis pas du tout mais il
ya la question de caisse qui est
rétrocédé sous forme de dividendes aux
actionnaires par rapport à ce qui va au
salaire salaire dans les entreprises à
faire inviter au sa menace des passes je
veux dire c'est une question plus
particulière que celle de la
comptabilité nationale fois de plus de
quoi parle-t-on et
98 % de notre tissu industriel
ce sont des tpe et des pme et pour
lequel l'actionnaire c'est l'actionnaire
familial en définitive oui et la
répartition du bénéfice dans le cas de
ces petites entreprises elle passe par
l'intéressement par la partition par les
pagnes par les primes mais ne croyons
pas que toute notre économie est dominé
par des entretiens aux questions
internationales diverses sur des des
profits et des dividendes qu'ils auront
obtenu grâce au couteau quoi qu'il en
coûte c'est absolument pas le des morts
denis jacquet à vous qui êtes
entrepreneur comment cette question du
partage des richesses concerne aussi les
pme viennent le dire d'ailleurs denis
par le craignait la baronne
way au faciès effet elle se fait aussi
au détriment des salariés aujourd'hui
cette partage de la richesse se partage
de la richesse
moi je dirais pas ça en france on en
fait quand vous voyez le taux d'impôt
marginal qui en france qui reste et qui
reste du champion du monde toutes
catégories pratiquement de l'imposition
enfin en position plus prélèvements
sociaux on reste les champions européens
est quasiment un des cinq leaders
mondiaux un malgré les différentes
économies qu'on a vu sur la taxe
d'habitation dont on va vite voir
quelles vont être compensés par les
augmentations de taxes foncières donc
tout ça va pas très peu profité à qui
que ce soit mais la première chose c'est
qu'un un système d'intéressement
monsieur le rappeler tout de suite un
système de participation mais qui à mon
avis n'est pas assez largement dire que
moi mon rêve c'est de faire une france
d'actionnaires ce whisky ce ski ce
shérif le plus qui gagne le plus et on
le voit bien aux états unis plus de 70 %
80 % des gens qui gagnent plus de 100 à
150 mille dollars ont une partie de leur
patrimoine amp entre avril 2020 février
mars et avril
2007 et est passé et maintenant ils ont
une augmentation de leur portefeuille
qui va jusqu'à 100 ou 150 semble donc
ils se sont enrichis pendant que les
autres qui ont des salaires plus faibles
se sont encore appauvri malgré les aides
du gouvernement américain est en france
c'est la même chose ya pa ucesa planque
du coup sûr est effectivement plus de
français actionnaire et le partage se
ferait beaucoup mieux moi je ce que
j'aimerais quand même rappeler c'est que
dans les actionnaires d'ing qui
s'enrichissent aujourd'hui dont on a
toujours tendance à les pointer un petit
peu du doigt il y en a 2 1 dans le monde
entier c'est ce qu'on appelait les fonds
de pension ceux qui payent les retraites
aux états unis mais aussi en france donc
quand on enrichit des actionnaires c'est
pas des méchants actionnaires qui vont
s'acheter des autres c'est des gens qui
vont le réinjecter dans le système et
notamment dans nos retraites et qui vont
payer les retraites à la fin du moins et
les deuxièmes effectivement c'est aussi
l'état parce que vos paroles à oublier
que l'état est actionnaire d'un certain
nombre de ces entreprises à petite ou à
grande échelle et qui lui permet de
récupérer aussi pou d'argent qui se
dépense très mal par ailleurs donc je
pense ça le système de répartition en
france est pas si mauvais on a un taux
marginal d'imposition qui est
hallucinant de problème c'est que la
répartition qu'en fait l'état et
l'utilisation qu'en fait l'état
aujourd'hui sur ces 30 dernières années
juste une catastrophe donc c'est pas ces
entreprises qui sont responsables c'est
des états défaillants on espérait tous
que ça changera avec macron ce n'a pas
été le cas et donc c'est toujours
toujours aussi mal géré aujourd'hui mais
c'est là où c'est là ce fait mal denis
jacquat je vous interromps parce que
c'est un tout petit peu long je ferrais
justement benjamin coriat et ensuite
daniel laborne vous venez de dire et
puis ensuite héros même disons je sens
que vous lirez agir oui bien sûr je
voulais réagir parce que nous donner
le la croissance des actions des
salariés américains les pauvres les
pauvres et sont bien oubliée 1 il n'y a
pas de retraite le seul moyen de faire
de la retraite c'est de mettre une
partie de leur salaire en actions et le
jour où ces actions vont baisser par
exemple le jour où ils vont partir à la
retraite on sait pas ce qu'ils vont
trouver donc je veux dire il faut pas
comparer ce qui est incomparable
heureusement nous avons un système de
protection sociale socialiser et ça nous
évite de devoir dépendre du cours des
actions ça c'est un premier point de ce
que je voulais dire la deuxième chose
que je voudrais dire quand même c'est
que or le cac40 parce que il n'ya pas
que le cac 40 dans la vie il faut
rappeler quand même que le taux de marge
des entreprises françaises aujourd'hui
est de 34% qu'il atteint un sommet
historique et que c'est pas pour rien
oui bien sûr c'est pas pour rien stade
hier bah c'est pas pour rien c'est à
dire qu'il y a eu une baisse de l'impôt
sur le revenu qu'il y a eu le cu c'est à
eux qu'il ya eu les impôts de production
bon et que donc il ya une politique de
l'offre entre guillemets en faveur des
entreprises systématique ce qui fait que
on en vient à notre sujet aujourd'hui il
ya un problème avec la reprise de
l'inflation du pouvoir d'achat parce que
la politique qui a été fait a été très
inégal erwan si l'on voulait peut-être
dire un mot là-dessus oui juste un
chiffre fin de deux chiffres tout le
respect que j'ai pour benjamin le ya
aucune distorsion dans le
la valeur ajoutée par rapport justement
salariés ou contrôler salariés juste en
1900 1949 à nice à dbayé encore
90% on est à 57 % aujourd'hui a été
parfaitement plat depuis 70 ans donc il
n'y a eu aucune piste torson du capital
en faveur justement aux actionnaires par
rapport aux séries c'est en 1900 entre
1982 et 1991 seule date correspondant
justement un gouvernement socialiste
c'est le seul moment où les salles à la
part des rémunérations des salariés dans
la valeur ajoutée a diminué sa a été en
baisse de 2 10% et on en est là non mais
ça sert ses revenus on est revenu en est
revenu sur la dignité avant car
on est à 57 % aujourd'hui donc il n'y a
aucune distorsion aujourd'hui en faveur
justement de qualité bon bien sûr faut
bien s'en faut bien savoir aussi que
lorsqu'une entreprise verse un dividende
à les actionnaires ce n'est pas du tout
du coup contre les salariés une
diminution de 2 des salaires derrière
faut savoir aussi que quand une
entreprise versant des dividendes mais
n'y a pas forcément d'augmentation non
plus en fait c'est ce que j'imagine
qu'on vous raconte marc orian gd
distribué 100 euros oui ça tours aux
pauvres qui sont en bas la dre delà des
limites de la dynamique d'augmentation
des salaires dépendent autre chose et
bien entendu de toute façon une
entreprise surtout dans le contexte
actuel quand l'ours cap réaliste
d'énormes bénéfices ou en tout cas d'une
forte augmentation de sa valeur ajoutée
elle a tout intérêt à augmenter s'avère
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on va lier
que du 1er janvier on a des
augmentations de salaires et surtout on
va on va y revenir sur ces augmentations
de salaires d'abord on va se rendre
compte que les salariés sont peut-être
pas totalement satisfait on peut se
poser la question en tout cas aux états
unis il démissionne en nombre on appelle
ça la grande démission de big couette en
anglais 38 millions d'américains qui ont
quitté leur entreprise en 2021 il ya
pénurie de main d'oeuvre regardez un
extrait de ce reportage de notre
correspondant matthieu mabin et fanny à
l'arrêt on en reparle ensuite
joe biden n'avait pas vu venir cette
crise
mobilisés par la pandémie et l'urgence
d'injecter des sommes considérables dans
l'économie par le biais de plans de
relance record le refus massif des
travailleurs américains de reprendre
leurs activités a pris l'administration
de cours
en tête des secteurs touchés la
restauration
quand les employés de la restauration
ont commencé à percevoir des indemnités
de chômage supérieure ou égale à leur
salaire ils ont soudain découvert leur
valeur réelle sur le marché et enfin pu
réaliser ce qui n'était plus prêt à
faire dans ce secteur
en 2000 21 7% des cuisiniers serveurs ou
parme n ont tout simplement refusé de
retourner au travail la baronne ça
arrive en france à même si marché du
travail beaucoup plus rigide cause est
alors le marché du travail est beaucoup
plus rigide mais c'est vrai que la
question des rémunérations la question
des conditions de travail la question du
sens que l'on donne à son travail tout
cela a fait réfléchir je crois durant la
période du confinement et de nouvelles
exigences sont apparues
de la part des salariés qui veulent être
mieux payés dans certains secteurs
d'activité qui veulent travailler dans
de meilleures conditions et qu'ils
veulent voilà orienter leur activité
professionnelle dans des activités qui
donne du sens alors à leur action ça
vaut pour laquelle moi je pense que les
secteurs qui sont en tension on pense
cafés hôtels restaurants brrr le seul
moyen pour régler le problème de la
pénurie nadal c'est d'augmenter les
rémunérations c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
été fait dans le cadre d'un accord passé
dans la branche professionnelle + 16 %
d'augmentation donc on voit bien que le
marché de toute manière va conduire à la
fois à des augmentations de
rémunérations dans les secteurs en
tension va conduire les les managers à
adapter peut-être les horaires les
conditions de travail en tenant compte
davantage des attentes et des
aspirations des salariés et puis
j'observe que nous avons 3500 micro
entrepreneurs qui s'inscrivent tous les
jours en ce moment en france benjamin
koré est aujourd'hui le salarié disait
on pèse plus dans le rapport de force au
sein des entreprises parce que justement
il ya pénurie de main d'oeuvre il ya ce
que ce phénomène que l'on voit aux états
unis peu être un petit peu en france
également écouter au globalement moi je
dirais que non ainsi les salariés
étaient capables de peser il aurait par
exemple empêcher la loi d'indemnisation
du chômage qui a été introduite et qui
est une loi invraisemblable un du point
de vue de l'abaissement des droits des
salariés alors c'est bien de se plaindre
de la condition de compatir à la
condition des salariés mais je veux dire
on commence pas par faire une loi sur le
chômage qui va pénaliser
des d'énormes quantités de salariés donc
ça c'est un premier point
c'est que dans certains secteurs
incontestablement c'est en train de
bouger c'est en train de bouger dans
l'hôtellerie restauration comme vous
l'avez signalé est effective à ces
jeunes il faut attirer les
insectes et au sein de bouge pas à qui
m'inquiète beaucoup 1 par exemple c'est
tout ce qui est la logistique c'est à
dire tout ce qui est les travailleurs
hubé risée et qui sont tant en
commanditant multiplication absolument
énorme et pour le moment on voit pas
beaucoup de changements là il ya un
autre secteur qui m'inquiète beaucoup
et c'est cette fois c'est du dieu mais
je suis d'accord avec vous sur un point
c'est plus des des questions de
demain c'est des questions qu'il faut
préciser qu'il faut localiser
sexy oui alors le secteur de la santé 1
dans lequel on n'arrive plus à pourvoir
les postes on est un point absolument
catastrophique sans qui ont augmenté les
salaires mais bien sûr il faut augmenter
les salaires et vous revoir les copies
et vous voyez bien que c'est pas fait
ils continuent à manifester toutes les
semaines en tout cas chaque fois qu'ils
peuvent non ça veut dire que les
promesses du ségur sont très très en
dessous à la fois de ce qui était espéré
de ce qui est nécessaire les
augmentations de rémunérations
salariales vous pouvez parler contestent
non mais je ne les conteste pas mais la
question c'est est-ce que c'est
suffisant dommage en terme d' aspiration
et en termes de consolidation d'un
secteur absolument crucial pour votre
vie la mienne et celle de tous les
français celles de la santé c'est ça la
question denis jacques r
benjamin coriat parlait justement de
vulgarisation vous connaît bien vous
connaissez bien ce secteur est ce qu'il
va y avoir aussi des augmentations de
salaires ou des changements de statut
auprès justement de tous et c'est de
tous ceux qui travaillent en fait dans
ce secteur précaire on peut dire
en fait j'essaie d'être court c'est vrai
que mon excuse par
la première pour rebondir avec respect
un nouveau et amitié benjamin c'est que
moi je pense que le droit français
condamne à la pauvreté au contraire mais
je veux prendre juste un exemple très
rapidement sur cette socialisation ici
en floride comme âme comme dans un
certain nombre d'états qui n'ont pas
fait peur aux gens avec cette hystérie
covidien les gens n'ont pas peur de
travailler qu'est ce qui se passe il ya
effectivement une tension sur
l'hôtellerie la restauration
je n'ai pas le temps de vous faire un
quiz mais je vais vous faire la réponse
est la question en même temps est-ce que
vous savez combien en moyenne un serveur
dans un bar ou un restaurant en hôtel
gagne ici à miami donc je vous la fait
courte la réponse est entre huit et
douze mille dollars par mois huit et
douze mille dollars mais pour autant ça
les a pas empêchés démissionner et
d'être beaucoup moins justement à se
bousculer à prendre ces jobs et il ya
deux choses sur la répartition
c'est-à-dire que la socialisation
condamne au minimum ici il n'ya pas de
maximum donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné quand vous gagnez 12000 je peux
vous dire que vous pouvez la préparer
votre retraite donc set pour revenir sur
le sujet de la répartition la deuxième
chose c'est que tous les états où on a
eu une forte pression sur la peur du coc
vide new york san francisco tuta su
jeter personne ne veut plus travailler
parce que tout le monde pense qu'il va
retourner au travail va tomber malade et
va mourir dans tous les états qui n'ont
pas succombé à cette folie furieuse il
ya moins de tensions sur l'emploi et
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que dans
l'est dans les états texas ecsta il ya
une forte tension mais moins la
troisième chose c'est qu'on a donné
beaucoup d'argent c'est jamais arrivé
aux etats-unis aux salariés pour qu'ils
tiennent le coup et c'était vraiment
indispensable trump l'a fait et
effectivement quand vous gagnez tout à
coup jusqu'à 2000 $ par semaine pendant
plusieurs mois pour l'instant il
retournera au travail parce que pour
l'instant ils ont suffisamment des
pagnes pour s'offrir des vacances qui
n'ont jamais eu je vous rappelle aux
états unis au bout de cinq ou six ans
d'ancienneté vous avez au mieux 15 jours
de vacances donc une force de reports
plus tôt c'est du report et enfin sur
l'ubs l'irisation ce que j'ai promis de
faire court puisque j'avais fondé
l'observateur dubé risation on avait
fait des propositions qui était forte
sur l'intégration de l'élévation sociale
des salariés dit hubert is et non pas en
les transformant en salariés mais en
faisant en sorte de que le choc social
s'augmente dont le seule chose qu'elle
ait pu faire ce gouvernement est votée
par les mets deux chambres récemment
c'est de décider que offrir du
syndicalisme à l'ubs et risation allait
régler le problème c'est juste n'importe
quoi donc on avait fait toutes les
propositions nécessaires pour ça et
d'ailleurs on avait même passé la main à
la caisse puisqu'on avait réussi à faire
en sorte notamment des livres ou qui est
un champion européen puisse offrir
gratuitement une mutuelle à ses 400
mille salariés dix-huit berries et
indépendant en europe sans besoin
d'avoir passé la voir passer par la case
salariés donc oui le sujet de
libéralisation et de cette économie n'a
pas été adressée non plus par ce
gouvernement pourtant on avait vraiment
travaillé en amont pour le faire et
c'est dommage parce que c'est un secteur
comme disait benjamin qui va aller de
façon exponentielle monsieur le député
rappeler qu'il ya de plus en plus de
micro entrepreneurs et d'auto
entrepreneur parce que c'est des gens
qui pensent ils voient là un trade
indépendant mais qui se retrouve face à
jean suite une situation où ils n'ont
pas le choix ils veulent rester
indépendant certes mais ils ont pas de
socle social donc il ya un vrai sujet a
dressé cap a été adressée dans les dix
dernières années notamment dans les cinq
dernières erwan si l'on vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que viennent dire denis
jacquet
oui moi je suis je suis d'accord et
notamment son analyse de lui du côté
outre atlantique mais vous savez sur le
sur le le je pense que la grande
résignation le grand raid cuisine comme
on en parle mais qui nous touche aussi
aussi en france aujourd'hui des regards
des entreprises qui ont un mal fou à
recruter ça ne se résoudra pas
uniquement par une question
d'augmentation de salaire pour toi parce
que quand vous regardez les différentes
enquêtes d'opinion et d'intention la
plupart des gens vous parlent aussi
surtout de leurs conditions de travail
j'en prends comme exemple par exemple
qui se passe à l'hôpital société
benjamin juste avant on a commis a pas
très longtemps un rapport par l'institut
a bien sûr justement le grand déficit
infirmiers le fait qu'ils aient
quasiment 20% des effectifs qui quitte
vraiment quand aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
c'est pas qu'une question de salaire
pour vous écouter les professionnels ils
vous disent que de la qualité au travail
et le management reviennent comme étant
les deux principaux tête des principales
défaillances qu'on peut avoir justement
lancer dans ce genre de structures là
quand dans certaines entreprises dans la
restauration par exemple ou la la la
prise de conscience a été clair et
limpide pendant la crise du crédit a
commenté effectivement vous rendez
compte que vous pouvez avoir eu soirée
que vous n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir des
pauses méridiennes imposé tous les jours
on pouvait voir vos week end a
effectivement vous changer de regard sur
votre sur votre métier quand vous l'êtes
plus au télétravail j'espère qu'on vous
l'avez vu un manager one management
toxiques et sur votre dos à faire un
micro management qui est improductif et
qui du coup de nuit complètement non
seulement votre motivation mieux si
votre épanouissement sein d'entreprises
mais effectivement vous rendez compte
que il ya d'autres choses d'autres
activités que vous pouvez faire c'est
pour ça que cette quête de sens cela ne
sera pas uniquement résolu avec des
augmentations de salaires elles sont
essentielles sont nécessaires et elles
sont de l'ordre de la négociation de
branche dans la plupart des secteurs
par exemple
excusez moi est ce qu'il faudrait
benjamin coriat augmenter le smic par
exemple le débat revient il est
d'augmenter en allemagne aux états unis
évidemment joe biden souhaitait
l'augmenter m'enfin il a les
républicains qui sont opposés en
angleterre manifestement au royaume uni
aussi il est question de l'augmenter ce
smic en france il ya un petit coup de
pouce mais toi oui on a été pendant très
longtemps pionnier était très en avance
en termes de smic par rapport à d'autres
pays mais c'est plus du tout le cas ça
veut dire que l'allemagne les etats-unis
l'angleterre sont en train de nous
rattraper à grande vitesse donc
dans l'état du dispositif actuel oui
bien sûr je suis favorable à une
augmentation du smic de combien il faut
savoir
on peut discuter mais si vous voulez la
difficulté significative
c'est qu'on a en france la difficulté
qu'on a en france c'est que les
travailleurs payés au smig non comment
dire
les employeurs ne paye quasiment zéro
charge bon donc honda on a on a un
système qui s'est progressivement
installée au cours du temps qui est très
pervers qui est très pervers parce que
si on avait un système de couverte de
deux prestations sociales si je peux
dire plus équilibré ça nous permettrait
de faire plus de choses en terme de
politique salariale mais dans tous les
cas il ya une urgence là il ya une
urgence non seulement pour ceux qui sont
privés de revenus mais pour tous les
travailleurs pauvres qui sont aussi
mises augmenter le smic vous aider ou
niant non je dis il ya une urgence il
faut augmenter le smig compte tenu de
l'urgence mais je ne dis pas que c'est
la meilleure solution trouver des
formules de revenu garanti pour les plus
pauvres avec des contreparties bien sur
deux vraies à mon avis être la solution
vers laquelle allez
merci
la question du pouvoir d'achat ne se
résume pas uniquement à la question de
la rémunération salariale
nous avons par exemple baisser les
impôts sur le revenu de 18 millions de
français nous avons mis en place un
système 2 0 reste à charge pour les
frais dentaires pour les prothèses
dentaires et pour les prothèses
auditives donc pour les lunettes et les
prothèses auditives pardon ça contribue
aussi à améliorer le pouvoir d'achat
deuxième point que je veux signaler
c'est que je suis assez d'accord avec ce
vin dire benjamin coriat nous avons un
système où jusqu'à 1,6 smic il ya plus
de charges patronales et et forcément
les les les entreprises est bien limitée
le smic jusqu'à sept blocs électriques
ainsi pouvoir bénéficier des avantages
de réduction des cotisations sociales
effet pervers dans d'autres allaient
peut-être qu'il faudrait relever ce
seuil de 1,6 peut-être jusqu'à 2,5
ensuite je crois que fondamentalement la
question de la rémunération salariale
c'est la question de la productivité si
on arrivait à avoir un système productif
qui dégage davantage de productivité
alors en même temps on pourrait
améliorer la rémunération salariale on
pourrait être un peu plus compétitive en
consacrant une partie de ses gains de
productivité à la baisse des prix de
vente des produits donc moi je considère
que la clé pour régler cette difficulté
de la rémunération salariale ces soldes
de l'innovation de la recherche mais
aussi c'est celle de la formation de la
qualification pour permettre à des
salariés d'avoir des niveaux de
formation qui leur permettent de
prétendre à de meilleures rémunérations
sur le marché du travail est-ce que les
salaires augmentent aussi vite que la
productivité en france ça dépend des
périodes là comme la productivité a
baissé il ya effectivement une
difficulté mais donc sur le fond je
crois qu'il ya aucun économiste qui
pourrait être en désaccord avec vous
c'est à dire que
la clef de l'augmentation des salaires
c'est effectivement l'absolu de
l'activité mais mais la distribution
primaire
est un problème et donc comment dire
indépendamment de ça il ya une vraie des
formations qui a été encore accrue dans
les dernières années et il ya un
rééquilibrage à faire donc je dirais
qu'il soit à rien qu'on dira entre accor
et bien moi je veux bien qu'on dise que
le cac 40 c'est le cac40 rendre les
entreprises par exemple on se souvient
de ce débat au moment de nicolas sarkozy
où il disait il faudrait un tiers de
dividendes un siège à demain de
rémunération pour les salariés et un
tiers pour les investisseurs notamment
imposer cela aux autres le maintien
c'est même un des leurs mules à l'écart
de rémunération non létaux l'argent des
profils à 1 on parlait des profits au
lieu de distribuer 60 à 80% en
dividendes on peut envisager hautepierre
jeu en tout cas ce que je voudrais dire
parce que l'émission sa chaise mais il
faut arrêter de ces petits cheese et les
choses des prélèvements sur des profits
exceptionnels d'entreprises qui ont
bénéficié de la crise pendant que toute
la france a subi la crise c'est une
chose parfaitement légitime et qui a été
exécuté de nombreuses fois je
rappellerai seulement prélèvements sur
les bénéfices que vous voulez bien sûr
mais peu un prélèvement sur des
bénéfices extraordinaires qui ont été
réalisés je voudrais juste rappeler un
peu ce que je sais pour ne pas aller
chercher mathusalem que le gouvernement
jospin pour lequel on a les sympathies
ou les antipathies qu'on veut c'est pas
du tout la question il a commencé par
prélever de l'argent sur d'ailleurs les
compagnies pétrolières pour commencer
son quinquennat donc je veux dire
problème aujourd'hui une fois qu'on a
vérifié que le quoi qu'il en coûte se
traduit par des distorsions si grande il
y a absolument aucun problème à faire
des prélèvements des licenciements sauf
si politiquement veut pas le faire
bientôt l'instant fermé le fleuve le
quoi qu'il en coûte il a
essentiellement profité aux tpe et aux
pme premiers points 2e temps en garde
les liteaux devra dire si un la
répartition de la richesse ne s'est pas
déformer entre les revenus du travail et
les revenus du capital ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure par un de nos
intervenants enfin il faudrait surtout
que les entreprises qui font du profit
les entreprises françaises qui font du
profit dans le reste du monde fasse leur
profit en france c'est-à-dire relocalise
leurs activités de production pour que
cela profite à son salarié concerné
localisation pour les revenus français
et à l'investissement français j'aurais
dire ça et vous savez que ça ne viendra
pas pourquoi mais parce que la
désindustrialisation en france ne fait
que s'accroître non mais non mais
écoutez c'est pas parce que il ya
cinquante entreprises qui ont annoncé
des investissements pour trente emplois
qui a acquis à une réindustrialisation
en france vont pas se moquer du monde il
ya une destinée désindustrialisation
massive et c'est ça qui explique je les
ai indiqué tout à l'heure la croissance
de la france c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
d'industrie qu'on n'est pas bloquée par
une imprimerie nationale dames simone
les cessions et des services aux
entreprises et aux sons l'organisation
du travail si avec la vie juan tison qui
fait moins intervenue et roanne tison il
y à cette tentative de total du groupe
total de mettre en place la semaine de
quatre jours pour attirer les jeunes
donc ces quatre jours de travail payées
5 est ce que c'est une bonne idée est ce
que ça prouve que même total a du mal à
embaucher
c'est une bonne idée ça total d'en
décider vous savez la semaine de quatre
jours le il faut suer avec la semaine
casio surtout pas refaire l'erreur qu'on
a fait que les 35 heures c'est à dire
d'imposer à toutes les entreprises de
tous les secteurs un temps de travail
minimum si vous avez les entreprises je
pense notamment à ldlc à lyon où ça
fonctionne très bien de quatre jours
parce que les personnes font leurs 35 40
heures sur 24 bref tout le monde y
trouve son compte mais il faut que ça
reste un tout simplement un accord
interne à l'entreprise une discussion
entre les salariés et la direction parce
que vous pouvez pas avoir la même chose
que ce soit dans l'hôtellerie
restauration ou des gens en manque de
bras si en plus vous leur dites qu'il
faut qu'il travaille un ou deux jours -
sets compliqués comme par exemple dans
des plateformes de livraison ou alors
dans certaines entreprises aux qu'il
faut que c'est une très belle idée si
celle ci s'est décidé en interne entre
les salariés et leurs représentants et
les encres et les employeurs denis
jacquet qu'en pensez vous un peu de
flexibilité également sur l'organisation
du travail ils le font peut-être en
allemagne plus que nous d'ailleurs
pourquoi en france d'ailleurs c'est si
compliqué sa part m plutôt ailleurs une
bonne idée parce qu'en france on veut
absolument mettre tout le monde dans la
même boîte à chaussures et donc on prend
une loi qui s'applique à tout le monde
c'est one size fits all donc c'est juste
si on commence à laisser l'état faire ça
on est mort au contraire aujourd'hui
c'est un peu plus de libéralisation qui
nous voudraient ça marche pas le droit
du travail depuis 30 ans condamne les
gens sains à la pauvreté et de honau
d'emplois ça protège qui sont dedans ça
empêche ceux qui sont à l'extérieur de
rentrée on le sait depuis trente ans on
est le pays qui est un peu plus forte
sur match depuis 30 ans donc à un moment
donné donc moi ça se passe la deuxième
jeu nos sections ceux ci on veut sur les
notions de mais je suis en france non
mais parce qu'on a beaucoup quand même
réformer le marché du travail depuis que
nous sommes en responsabilité
nous avons également réformer la
fiscalité du capital nous avons beaucoup
aux vrais pour l'innovation la recherche
le développement nous avons développé
l'apprentissage des jeunes nous avions
300 milles apprentis nous en sommes à
750 milles donc je veux dire nous avons
quand même progresser sur un certain
nombre de plans pour faire en sorte que
notre économie soit à la fois plus
attractive plus compétitive et plus
productive chez le député j'aimerais
bien que je sais que la république en
marche même pas partager la parole
denis jacquat l'isi la chimère de la
reproduction en france et de la
relocalisation c'est une chimère total
venir la production aujourd'hui quand
elle se relocalise elle est totalement
automatisé donc elle elle produit
extrêmement d'emplois regardez amazon
quand vous comparez une boîte
traditionnel un walmart et amazon l'auto
d'emploi il est de 40 fois inférieur
donc c'est pas ça qui crée de l'emploi
et puis quand on attend non monsieur le
député je veux bien tout ce ne voulait
pas commencé à réformer pendant un an et
demi après tout c'est stopper mais nous
peinons à la main c'est que le président
macron s'aperçoit en fin de quinquennat
six mois avant les élections qui font un
plan sur le numérique que nous ont
réclamé qu'on lui avait vendu déjà ya
cinq ou six ans quand il était à
l'elysée et qu'il n'a jamais fait et de
ce plan du numérique monsieur le député
vous voulez nous le rappeler 30
milliards sur cinq ans six milliards par
an c'est moins que ce que consacre la
dixième ville chinoise juste sur le
sujet de l'intelligence à venir sur le
le partage on va revenir dans le partage
des revenus de jack et nous reste je
voudrais juste que chacun puisse
conclure tout de même justement sur ce
partage de la valeur ajoutée qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire s'il y avait une
réforme à faire benjamin coriat moi je
dirais que incontestablement il faut il
faut aller vers une formule de revenu
minimum garanti pour s'assurer que il
n'y ait plus de pauvreté en france
que l'on cesse avec la situation dans
laquelle un ménage sur six ne peut pas
se chauffer pendant l'hiver donc je veux
dire le dispositif pratique est ce que
c'est des prestations en nature sbc des
prestations monétaire c'est à discuter
mais il faut aller vers des formules de
revenu minimum garanti que l'on soit le
hac actifs ou que l'on soit au moi je
suis intimement convaincu qu'il faut
d'abord se préoccuper de la création de
richesse dans notre économie pour
ensuite envisager la distribution de la
richesse et je considère que en mettant
en place une politique d'offres c'est à
dire une politique qui se préoccupent
aux conditions d'amélioration de
l'efficacité productive de notre
appareil de production et bien nous
avons là la clé de l'amélioration de la
productivité de notre de notre économie
et d quand nous aurons de la
productivité alors nous pourrons mieux
répartir sans doute les dividendes de
cette croissance zéro en disant
si on pense que c'est dommageable
effectivement que les dividendes ne
profite qu'à une poignée d'actionnaires
faisons en sorte que tout simplement
d'augmenter le nombre d'actionnaires on
fait en sorte que chaque salarié chaque
personne chaque citoyen puisse devenir
actionnaire de n'importe quelle
entreprise pas forcément la sienne ça
passe par de levier premièrement des
mécanismes incitatifs à l'investissement
dans l'économie productive et
deuxièmement la mise en place d'une
forme de retraite par capitalisation
pour profiter pour qu faire en sorte que
le profit justement du capitalisme et de
la tête capitalisation la 10e profiter
un maximum de personnes et que tout le
monde puisse vivre d'autres revenus que
de son seul revenu salarial tous
capitaliste denis jacquet
tout à fait d'accord avec avec erwan
la chose c'est ça c'était en fait ce que
nous a proposée
ou le x 4 et on a un truc raisonnable si
on met 100 milliards sur la table et
qu'on s'associe au niveau de l'europe
pour avoir un avenir numérique avec des
géants de lumière oui on va créer de la
richesse oui on va créer de l'emploi
chez vous chez nous oui on va créer des
impôts des taxes qui vont perfusé toute
l'économie mais pour l'instant on
l'attend toujours merci beaucoup denis
jacquat merci à vous et roanne disons
merci daniel la baronne avons été avec
nous merci benjamin coriat merci à vous
tous deux avoir suivis et reste avec
nous sans fond 34
[Musique]
il